I used to like this one you kind of push
out quite far from the pole adult
entertainment has thrived in Edinburgh
for decades but as Council plans to shut
down the city's strip clubs dancers Say
it'll be financially devastating it's
potentially pretty disastrous because
it's it makes up a lot of my income so
yeah I mean I I don't know where I'd be
without it at the moment as a parent I I
mean I just find it really flexible and
you know there's the potential for it to
be well paid so that's it takes a lot of
boxes for me as a parent I'm very
disappointed this is the moment the City
of Edinburgh Council voted to ban all
strip clubs from April 2023. sure that
meant that my counselor Griffith has
been carried but three clubs and the
union are now challenging the council's
decision at a judicial review
behind the council's decision and the
subsequent judicial review challenge
there's a feminist debate going on on
one side the women who believe it should
be their choice to work in sexual
entertainment venues and on the other
those who believe the best way to
prevent violence against women is to ban
strip clubs altogether when I was a
young counselor in the 90s I supported
the licensing of saunas which were then
used as brothels a drug and HIV crisis
in the early 90s meant Susan delgeti
voted for regulation as a public health
issue I have changed my mind since then
as a feminist I think that men
paying us for sexual favors is the worst
kind of exploitation of our bodies and
it is the epitome of the patriarchy but
many argue closing strip clubs could
pressure women into riskier work
shutting down uh legal regulated place
of work for dancers who are primarily
women would force them to work in more
dangerous conditions especially during a
cost of living crisis sex workers and
strippers are not to be blamed for
exploitation and sexual violence for
dancers like Sasha it's about autonomy I
think that that is our right to choose
that and I don't think it's right for a
feminists to tell women what they should
and shouldn't be doing with their bodies
but with the judicial review decision
expected to take several weeks Showtime
could be over for edinburgh's strip
clubs its employees and those who make
their living on the stage Jason manzaray
Sky News